[Musique]
comme chaque année à la fin du ramadan
la communauté musulmane de l'île a été
convié par le président du département
cyrille melchior a célébré l'aïd el fitr
une cérémonie organisée ce dimanche 22
mai 2022 dans les jardins de la villa du
département
notre île de la réunion est une île de
partage de solidarité de tolérance et il
était important bien évidemment que à
l'occasion de la fin du ramadan que l'on
puisse célébrer cette fête avec nos
frères et soeurs de confession musulmane
par bob deux ans
malheureusement à cause de la précarité
et bien toutes ces festivités se sont
faites à l'intérieur des familles mais
pas de façon ou rassemblé pas moins de
ces bois cela que je suis un président
content heureux d'avoir pu organiser
avec des services du département je
salue le travail les associations
musulmanes sur tout le territoire de la
réunion
cette belle journée doit honorer encore
une fois l'aide profite soyeuse fête à
tous leurs faits et gestes du professeur
un moment de convivialité et de fête qui
s'est tenue en présence du président du
conseil régional du culte musulman
nazir patel c'est une vraie joie et je
remercie chaleureusement le président
fit si quelqu'un les élus et puis tous
les agents du département qui ont uvré
célébrer cette journée de façon
magnifique vraiment c'est quelque chose
d'exceptionnel de beaux donc dans le
coran on dit dieu aime la beauté et la
franchement il ya de la beauté il ya du
partage il ya de la convivialité et puis
il ya une manière de voir la laïcité qui
nous est propre à la réunion
c'est une vraie laïcité inclusive qui ne
cherchent pas au contraire à exclure
laetitia qui a rassemblé à réunir dans
un monde plus apaisée différents
différentes personnes riches de nos
singularités riche de la pluralité
pour l'occasion les visiteurs étaient
invités à découvrir plusieurs stands et
ateliers calligraphie arabe est née
cosmétiques expositions ou encore
dégustation de thé
en tout
une dégustation de pâtisseries à
l'orientale ainsi que
une présentation du couscous de
l'autorité donc c'est un couscous
marocain recettes légumes avec une
présentation comme vous voyez ici à
l'orientale des millet et la pâtisserie
avec le thé à la menthe qui va arriver
tout à l'heure je présente des tableaux
j'ai intitulé l'exposition vibrations
d'ici et d'ailleurs parce que je suis
d'ailleurs je suis du maroc je peins le
maroc avec la belle couleur de la
réunion je m'inspire de deux paysages
après je fais à ma manière parce que
j'aime créer c'est pour ça le titre
libération d'ici et d'ailleurs
la cérémonie de l'aïd à la villa du
département a été ponctuée de lectures
et de chants et s'est clôturée par un
moment de partage comme le veut la
tradition
[Musique]